PROFESSOR: The molecules and
Born-Oppenheimer approximation.
OK, we all know
that molecules are
a lot harder to
solve than atoms,
and even atoms are
not that easy once you
have more than one
electron because
of the electrostatic
repulsion, but molecules
are significantly different
in that one of the greatest
simplicities that
we had with atoms
is that the atom is such
that the potential created
by the nucleus is
spherically symmetric.
When you have a molecule
you have separate nuclei
and therefore your
spherical symmetry is gone,
and whether you
have one electron
or more than one electron,
there is no spherical symmetry.
All our tools of angular
momentum don't help us much.
We have to start
the problem anew.
So the difficulty with
molecules is basically
that the potential for the
electrons, where they move
is not spherically symmetric.
There is another
thing that helps
us, however, is that there's a
nice separation of mass scales.
You have the mass,
little m, of the electron
and the nuclear mass, this
could be the mass of one nucleus
or a mass of a few
nuclei or doesn't matter,
but this is small, and typically
it is 10 to the minus 4.
You know, an electron is
about 2,000 times lighter
than a single proton.
If you already have a nice
nucleus with a couple of them,
you're several
thousandths already there,
so this is a nice number.
So we want to understand the
scales of the physics of this,
so let's assume we
have a molecule,
maybe a has few centers and
then there's electronic cloud,
and it has a size
of the order of a.
So we can estimate
at first sight what
are the energies involved here?
What is the energy of the
electron, for example?
And you can say the
momentum of the electron
is of the order of h bar
times the size of the cloud.
It's an estimate, and the
energies, the electron
energies, are
basically determined
by the size in which
there are confined,
which is a, h bar, and
the mass of the electron.
Those are the electronic
energy, so h squared over
m a squared, those
are the right units,
is p squared over m, the units,
so it's natural like this.
So this is the
electronic configuration
and typical electronic
energy, so what
is the approximate picture
of the physics of a molecule?
Basically you have nuclei, and
the nuclei repel each other,
they want to be away.
Now the electrons
come in and then they
fly around the nuclei, and the
electrons attract the nuclei
and attract the nuclei, so the
electrons, reasonably placed,
compensate the
repulsion of the nuclei
by creating some new attraction.
At the end you get some
kind of equilibrium.
It's not classical because
you cannot create stable
equilibrium between
classical particles.
This is one of the amazing
things about quantum mechanics.
You know very well
an atom would not
exist without quantum
mechanics, you
would have stable classical
orbits, circular orbits,
but they radiate
energy so they decay.
If you have a molecule you
have two repelling positive
charged particles.
In [? E&M ?] you
saw the case when
you put the negative
charge in the middle
and you create equilibrium,
but that's absolutely unstable.
You move that electric charge
a micron and then off it goes,
the whole thing is unstable.
But quantum mechanics
solves those problems
and our physical picture is
that of repelling nuclei,
an attracting cloud
of electrons creating
an equilibrium in which
the nuclei are reasonably
well-localized, they're
quantum particles
but they're reasonably
well-localized,
while the electrons are
completely delocalized.
That is our picture, they
are moving in that way.
So our picture will
be-- we have that
and we have slow vibrations
of the nuclei that
are mostly localized.
And you can imagine calculating
the electronic configuration
for any particular
separation of the nuclei
and that's the cloud
for this separation.
As the nuclei vibrate, the
electronic configuration
probably adjusts
adiabatically to this thing
in the instantaneous
eigenstates,
and they work that way.
We're going to do that in
trying to understand things.
I also want to
emphasize this kind
of remarkable property
of an electron
to create the bound state.
So we are not amazed on the
fact that if we have a proton
and we can have an electron
here, we create a bound state,
and that's a hydrogen atom.
But suppose I bring in
another proton from infinity.
Well, I-- if I
bring it, I'm going
to start bringing it here,
this kind of is neutral
but eventually this proton
is gonna polarize this thing.
OK, I'm going to bring it
and then if I come too close
it repels it so it will
be a force repelling it
and we have to figure
out what it does.
Suppose I try to bring it in.
Do you think that an electron
is capable of stabilizing
two protons?
Can they create a cloud in which
an electron stabilizes the two
protons?
Is that possible
or not possible?
There's a lot of protons
for one single electron.
Is that possible or not?
All right, you say yes,
yes, any other opinions?
Can that happen?
Can the electric produce a bound
state of two protons like that?
AUDIENCE: Isn't
that just hydrogen?
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Isn't
that just hydrogen?
PROFESSOR: It is what?
AUDIENCE: Isn't
that just hydrogen?
Or [INAUDIBLE]
hydrogen [INAUDIBLE]??
PROFESSOR: OK, yes,
it can produce it,
and this would be called,
with an electron here,
the hydrogen
molecule ion, so H2+.
It's a hydrogen molecule
that had these two things
and it lost one electron,
and yes, this can be done
and we'll analyze it.
And now you can
get greedy and say,
can you get an electron to
stabilize three protons?
Yes or no?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: No, cannot get
it, it's just too much work
for an electron.
It cannot do it.
There are theorems
like that, Elliott
Lieb, a mathematical
physicist, has proven
all kinds of these
things, and we
might discuss some of
that in the homework,
it's kind of nice stuff.
So we will be looking at
the physics of those things
with a little detail.
So now of let's go
back to our molecule
here and estimate the
vibrational nuclear energy.
So we have this picture,
the electrons are there,
the nuclei are kind
of semi-classical,
they are roughly localized
and they're varying,
and how would we estimate the
nuclear vibration frequency?
So estimate nuclear vibration.
So we think of a
harmonic oscillator,
b squared over 2
mass of the nucleons,
plus a restoring force,
H subnuclear oscillation.
So this is an estimate so
it's not very rigorous,
but I think it will
be clear enough.
Now this restoring
force has to do
with the cloud of the electrons
that adjusts and does things.
As you separate
the nuclei you have
to restore the
restoring energies
due to the electrons
and the Coulomb forces,
but it does not depend on the
mass, M, the restoring force.
So this k depends on the
electrons and Coulomb forces
but definitely not on the
mass of this quantity.
So k has units of
E over L squared,
and for energy we
have this energy
of the electron and
length, the length,
the scale of the molecule,
so k is proportional to h
squared over ma to the fourth.
It just cannot depend on
the mass of the nuclei,
that's definitely not the
origin of the restoring force,
so if the only mass you can use
is the mass of the electron it
can only be that.
But then the frequency,
omega, is square root
of k over M, that is
the mass of the nuclei,
so the nuclear
frequency is this,
and it's therefore
equal to h squared
over ma fourth one
over M, that was k,
and this is square root of
little m over capital M times
square root of h squared over
m squared a to the fourth,
I borrowed a little m
up and a little m down.
So from here we get
that h bar omega
nuclear is square root of
little m over capital M,
h squared over ma squared.
If you take the square root here
you get h bar over ma squared,
but there was another
h bar I put in.
And now we get a
sensible equation
in which we see that the
nuclear energies for oscillation
are much smaller,
significantly smaller,
so E nuclear oscillations go
like square root of m over M
is 10 to the minus 4,
we say square root is 10
to the minus 2,
times E electronic.
So it's considerably less which
is this, so if you think--
I want to make another
observation here on timescales,
so omega n, we have
it here, omega n,
or we have it here as well,
is equal to this times
this quantity, so let
me say it this way.
The omega electronic
for vibrations
is the electronic energy divided
by h bar, I need h bar over ma
squared, but here we see
that that's precisely
that square root, so
the omega nuclear is
equal to little m over
M omega electronic.
Now that is nice because it says
that the frequency associated
to the nuclear thing
is much smaller
than the timescales associated
with electronic changes.
So this is a good reason
for our idiomatic thinking
that as the nuclei
slowly oscillate,
the electronic cloud remains
in that particular eigenstate
and thus and jump.
It's our use of the
adiabatic approximation.
A last comment is that
the rotational energy
of the molecule goes like
the angular momentum squared
over twice the
moment of inertia,
L squared is h squared
times some numbers,
as usual, L times
L plus 1, and here
you get the mass of the
molecule times the size squared
of the molecule.
These energies are like
little m over capital M times,
this is roughly h squared
over little ma squared,
and therefore the
rotational energies
are even smaller than
the electronic energies.
The rotational energies
go like little m
over capital M times
the electronic energies.
So you have the electronic
energies, the nuclear energies
of oscillation, which
go like square root,
and then finally
the smallest of them
are the rotation, in
which the molecule rotates
like a solid object.
We'll continue this next
time and calculate a few more
things and molecules.